bonjour à vous merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation en direct sur rt france
alors ce que vous dénoncez un conflit
d'intérêt bien entendu pour dénoncer un
conflit d'intérêt il faut quand même
rappeler que blackrock c'est une
entreprise qui est impliqué en ce moment
dans des éco site qui est actionnaire
dans des dans des sociétés pétrolières
c'est une société qui multiplie les
déclarations de bonnes intentions et de
greenwashing
mais qui dans les faits détient 87
milliards d'actifs dans des sociétés
pétrolières donc bien entendu que nous
on a on a plus qu'une méfiance en fait
on est complètement scandalisés du fait
que blackrock puisse avoir été choisi
par la commission européenne pour
remplir ce rôle si une société également
qui soutient le gouvernement français
dans ses réformes c'est notamment le cas
sur la réforme des retraites est ce que
vous avez des informations sur le sur la
réforme des retraites ce qu'il faut se
dire c'est que blackrock c'est pas une
ong mais c'est pas une institution qui a
pour des missions d'intérêt général est
en fait elles sont intéressés de prendre
ma retraite par capitalisation puisqu'en
fait c'est la retraite va lui permettre
d'injecter de l'argent dans l'économie
est en fait de faire fructifier les
intérêts de ses actionnaires dont
blackrock a tout intérêt à ce que l'on
soit plus sur un modèle d'état
providence de retraite par la direction
est en fait bien quoique là vraiment
tout intérêt à détruire notre modèle
social et à pouvoir promouvoir des
retraites qui serve les intérêts privés
pour revenir justement au contrat kelly
blackrock la commission européenne il ya
eu un appel d'offres en toute légalité
ça ne nous rassure pas bien sûr que non
parce qu'en fait la question c'est pas
de savoir s'il y avait d'autres
concurrence savoir que comment est ce
que ça peut paraître logique de demander
à l'institution qui fait partie des
institutions qui sont les plus à la
source du problème dans lequel on est
autant social qu'environnemental
d'élaborer des solutions section c'est
complètement absurde et les personnes
qui parlaient avant moi l'ont rappelé
après juste titre c'est exactement comme
si on demandait à monsanto d'élaborer
des plans pour la filière du rock comme
si on demandait à total
et et de nouvelles amours et les plans
pour sortir du pétrole c'est juste
quelque chose dans lequel on est en
train de demander à quelqu'un qui à
l'origine du problème de créer la
solution est d'aller contre ses intérêts
et encore une fois de la crainte n'est
pas une once et ils ont aucun intérêt
financier ou moral à aller à l'encontre
de leurs intérêts de la raison d'être
c'est un contrat de l'ordre de 550 mille
euros 1 qui lie blackrock à
l'institution européenne pour s'assurer
que blackrock vous son rôle
honnêtement coco demandez-vous
qu'espérez vous en faites là ce qu'on
espère c'est que la commission
européenne va revenir sur sa décision et
en fait c'est pas possible que black
hole alors à son niveau d'implication et
de 2 dans les skis ce mandant des
énergies sales et dans tout un tas
conflits d'intérêts puisse remplir
efficacement sa mission
c'est une c'est une mascarade dans tous
les cas on peut pas on peut pas peut pas
faire quelque chose de durable avec
petrov
c'est là au delà du contrat qui est un
contrat qui va être payée par l'argent
des contribuables
on est sur la possibilité pour blackrock
d'entrer dans la bergerie et on est en
train de c'est une espèce
on est en train de leur laisser carte
blanche pour conseiller des institutions
qui devrait servir notre intérêt en tant
que citoyen la servir l'intérêt général
et on demande sa à des institutions qui
sont parmi les pires et parmi celles qui
sont le plus à l'origine du problème de
ce qu'on peut trouver dans le système
actuel
merci beaucoup marie koré je rappelle
que vous êtes un activiste alternatiba
merci à vous merci